- I need to let other people know
there's a reason why I'm alone, you know,
it's not cuz I'm alone.
(jazzy music)
My name's Eli and I'm single.
I'm like super single,
I'm like drinking merlot,
watching Parks and Rec on
a Saturday night single,
that's like how single I am.
I don't really go out alone by myself.
I mean, I think it's just really awkward.
I'm hoping throughout this week
I just learn to be more
comfortable with myself
and to be more comfortable being alone.
So we're gonna have to
do a dinner by ourselves,
go to the movies,
and $50 to do a date activity.
This is the only time I'm unhappy
that I'm having this
much money for dinner.
(instrumental music)
I've only went out to eat by myself once.
I went to a restaurant.
I lasted all of like 10 minutes.
I got the menu, I felt like
everyone was staring at me,
I had all this anxiety, and I
just got the hell out of there
so I'm hoping I can beat
that anxiety this week.
Well it is the date portion
where I eat dinner by myself.
I love Benihana so I wanted to go there.
Currently alone,
sitting by myself,
doing blogs as an excuse
to not look like a creepy idiot.
The wait staff's reactions
were similar to me
like buying condoms at a store, it's like,
oh, oh yeah, yeah, no whatever, whatever,
just hide it, we'll just, here you go.
There was a family there,
you know, naturally we started talking
and got to know them.
(laughing)
(people groaning)
- [Man] No head butts.
- You know it really
forces you to socialize,
kinda face those insecurities
head on, which is kinda cool.
(people cheering)
I'm late to the movie.
I was like a half hour late to the movie
so I pretty much bailed on myself.
This is why I'm single.
So now I am having a drink
until the next showing.
Needing one seat, I could
pretty much sit wherever I want.
While they're ringing me up,
I had all these couples in the other lines
like struggling to find like good seats
at the same movie.
I lasted half hour by myself.
I think I'm doing pretty good.
- [Man] Hello hello hello,
how's everybody doing today?
- Woo.
(female laughing)
I ended up going into the movie theater
and my seat was seat 20
and there was a girl sitting at 21,
and I assumed someone was gonna meet her,
probably get popcorn for her or something.
The movie starts and she's by herself
and I was, I have to talk
to this girl afterwards.
So I didn't sit next to
you because I assumed
someone was coming to sit next to you.
- No one was coming.
I think it's important
to take time for yourself
and be with your own self and be confident
in going out by yourself.
- True, I need that cuz I feel like
insecure or I feel like there's
yeah, the world, the world sets it up,
so if you're alone, you
look sad or something.
- Yeah, I find that stupid.
- This is really strange,
I thought you were, you may like,
hit me with your purse or run away
by me asking.
- No, people are afraid
of like actual interaction
with other people.
- Changing the world.
Don't use your cell phones.
I think the fact that
I went on a date alone
and then I met someone
is a success in itself.
I'm noticing being alone,
I'm not worried about
having to cater to somebody else.
Like I can just kinda let my guard down
and kinda like almost recharge in a way
and I don't have to constantly
worry about the other person.
So it's date number three
and I've had a hard time
trying to figure out
what I like to do for a date
so I think I'm gonna do
something a little more chill.
I decided to do a picnic in my backyard
with just me.
So I bought some wine
and I got chicken wings,
mac and cheese, balled out.
Yes, yes, this is a beautiful thing.
I'm a simple guy, all I
want is mac and cheese.
And I didn't have a blanket,
so I had an inflatable mattress
and I just threw it in
my backyard (laughing).
As far as the third date goes,
I don't think I've ever
done anything like that
with myself.
Might be the wine
talking, but I don't know,
I really needed this.
It's really therapeutic, it's almost like
kinda like meditation.
Out of all the dates,
I think that was probably the best one.
A, because I love chicken wings
and two, I was kinda really able
just to be in my own head.
(instrumental music)
My week was great.
I feel like when I go to these things,
when you're with someone,
you're just kinda catering to that person
and giving your energy to them.
It was almost like a meditation
just to kinda cater to me.
When you're alone, you're
willing to give your energy
within yourself and kinda be
open to the world around you.
This gave me confidence to be by myself.
If you resent the idea of going out alone,
hey, I get it, but all you really need
is like a glass of wine and a nice book
and you only look smart
and you only look that much sexier.
(instrumental music)